[音楽]
皆さんこんにちは今日はスピーチ r ケアというものについてお話したいと思うん
ですけれども皆さんのほとんどはおそらく初めて聞く言葉なんじゃないかと思います
イメージされることもおそらく様々なんじゃないかと思うんですけれどもアメリカでは
あの教育省にいん亭されている公的なと
5弾をとして存在してるんですねもっともあの
最も困難な状況にある人の心身のケアを
たように支援するというものなんですけれどもほかの国でも例えば自分の国プログラム
に取り入れたいとか
グローバルスタンダードにしようと w 庁が検討したりとかそういうのことがあり
ます
要は世界をとつながって世界をつなげるというような形でスピリチュアルケアというの
が検討されているんですけれども
やばそうなりますとまぁ世界で最も困ってる人たちを支援するためのスピリチュアル
ケア
ということになるんですがそれは実際はどうなんだろうということなんですね
そして今日はキーワードとして大和教育
た車
あとですねまあお互い相互の信頼と尊敬尊重ということをキーワードに8皆さんと一緒
にですね
このスピーチ r キャーという一体何なのかということを具体的な
実連をですね交えながら
特に今宗教の2つの側面ということですね
背景に一緒に考えていきたいというふうに思います
まず最初にですね私の子供の頃のちょっと思い出と言いますかそこからお話を始めさせ
ていただきたいと思います
私の家族にですね神社の境内で事故に遭って大怪我した人がいたんですねただ私が
生まれるも何年も前のことで私はもちろんしれません
でそのまま地域でよく神社の携帯が遊びはだったので私の遊んでいたんですがそのとき
にピン女のですよいつも親切な感じのおばあちゃまですね
馬車もがですねお孫さんと一緒に遊んでた孫さんたちに向かってこう言ったんです
あの子と遊んじゃいけないよあの子はねえ神社でけがをした人のうちの子だからって
言ったんです
でおそらく私はまだ同地にも上がる前
てすごく小さかったのでわからないんだろうと思ったんですよ
あの量は縁起が悪いということですですけれども子供心にすごく嫌な思いをした
嫌な気持ちになったの覚えてるんですね
他のじゃあおばさん達も出家地元の人たちはどうだったかというと非常ににこやかです
ねよかの神社やお寺でお正月とか
お盆難点ですねあのコミュニティの活動してとてもにこやかに行動等もシェアをして
くれて私もとても親切にあの付き合って笑いかけたり花
仕掛けたりしてくれている人たちでしたお餅とかお菓子を配ってもらったりして
技やは各店を進行は何もない家だったんですけれども
味元がまあそういうふうに信仰に厚いていますかそういう土地がだったので私の子供の
時の思い出っていうのはそういったいろんなまあ信仰や宗教に関連したり秒イベントと
いうのはたくさんエピソードとしてあの起伏を中に残っています
エイ
でこのことで思い出したのがですね
まあ
今日予想まあ式乳はいていっちゃ良いのもも含めてなんですがそのいろんなことを言わ
れたり行われてその言説っていうものが要はですね
人を支えたり励ましたりしてくれるようなものなのかそれとも
要はですねまぁ差別的だったり結果人を傷つけるようなものだったりするのか
2つの側面ですねどっちなんだろうっていうのまあそういったことをきっかけに考えた
わけですね
で歌氏はのフルブライト奨学金アメリカに留学する前にスイスであのを学んでいた経験
があるんですけれども
研究と支援活動情報で難民の方達の精神保健支援活動が非常に強い関心があって
a そういったことに関わっていました
その時はですね今いる
例えばそう w 長とか
国際赤十字とか
あと国連の難民支援法等
長いですねこのトホホ10
弁務官ありがとうございます米粉完治も知ってありますよね
そういった所や他の関連の npo や ngo
いうような暖帯林たビューを受けてインターンシップ参加したいということをいろいろ
な方の話を聞きましたみなさん本当に素晴らしい方たちでディスカッションもニュース
が入りましたし実際
剃っちゃう方に振動を進めてみようかなと思ったことも多々あったんです
ただあったんですけれどもあとでですね
いろいろ感じることを疑問が出てきたんですね
そういった方たちは実際にあのまあ仕事の場
研究の場とかでその研究者宗教者いろんな形が一緒なんですけれども非常に真面目で
精錬で熱心な支援活動の話をされるんですけれども同時にですね町で公的な場じゃない
ところです
あの指摘者はプライベート音声駅で例えばな
みんだった方たちとの当時清掃員とかにはしとか抑えて大変な高生活を抑えてて
まあ日常生活者であったりするんですよねそうするとですね
私も一緒にいるんですが変えれば突然態度を豹変させるプットとかあったんですよ
でそれを見ていてですねまあちょうどその時期というのはスイスに
まあコソボ紛争があってアルバニア系の難民の人たちがたくさん授乳している時でまぁ
今で言うためにいうに難民の人たちがたくさん入ってくるニュースをみなさんもご覧に
なっていると思いますがまあそれをちょっと想起させるような状況だったんです
ね歴史的に見ると
要は違う武侠あの宗教異文化異民族の人たちというのは
ある意味自分たちは全く違う他者であると
で他者であるならばまぁ早い話をですね
人間じゃないぐらいのですね扱いっていうのが例えば古代とか
中世とか金瀬現在よりもずっとさかのぼる以前はむしろそちらの方が当たり前だった
時代がありました
私も遠くから学校から来ている外国人が海南とって悪いた者ですから
同様じゃなくてですねそういう予防な状況でももし彼らに会ってたら果たしてどこだっ
たんだろう
私も排除されたり差別されたりしたんだろうっていう風
考えたりしたんですね
実際のところま宗教の2つの側面です
人を助ける救済するようなものなんだろうかそれとも差別したり
その結果相手を傷つけたりする表なそういうもんなんだろうか
こういう疑問がまた私の中に巻いてきたわけなんです
まあ書状研究してみよう実戦にもつなげる形で研究してみようということでまぁこの
至っています
その後 a まあ医療人類学とか社会学人将臣時間を微今日して
博士過程でも宗教学政治哲学社会に磨く等々
勉強そんなに好きじゃない返事素顔と思うとなんでだろうと思って気がついたらそんな
になってい
状況なんですがアメリカに行ってですねまぁそういう問題を書く関心を持つ流れた時に
スピリチュアルケアというものでありました
スピリチュアルケアというのは
病院チャプレンと言われる人たちがですね宗教的な中立なんだ
そういう標榜しながら a 宗教的な多様な背景を持っている患者さんたちを心身の
キャンを含めて支援するという8さっきも言いましたがアメリカの教育省では認定され
ているような法的なプログラムというのがあるん
ですね
先ほど言ったような問題関心の私の中にあったものですから
同じようなまあ構造がその中にメイトわけです確かに素晴らしいんだけれども本当は
どうなんだろう
本人もどこにも良い事は大体書いてあるんですよね本当はどうなんだ問題無いんだろう
か実際自分の目で見てみたいとそういうふうに考えて
そのプラグプログラムに参加しましたで今日はですね
その中で実際にあったあの事例を2つご紹介しながら一緒に考えてみたいと思います
まず最初にお話しする
丁火ドラマと書いてありますが日系人の女性の方です中年ぐらいの形で
たい日を患ってらっしゃいました長い間慢性疾患を患っていらして
その時は非常に安定された状況だったんですがまた発作掛けると危ないというような
状況の方でした
で専任の業員ちゃプレートは男性の牧師さんで真楽の博士をとっていらっしゃるような
方だったんですけれどもその方がですね
や彼女とお話をすると全然スピリチュアルな事件にならないと
どんなにですね聖書の話とか真面目にしようと思ってもお金のテレビドラマの話にしか
ならないと
de bossa 塩だけ君が日本から来てるし
日系人の人が知って見てんじゃないかという話になって
流出ホームをするということになりました
確かに彼女の病室訪問した時一番最終までも忘れないんですが2時間ぐらい
ドラマとは違うんですね続けて聞かされてですね
ですけど熱心に聴いている中でですね
彼女自身の抱えている例えばその病気に対する不安とか家族との問題とかそういった
ことがドラマの話を通じてなされているんだっていうのがわかったんですね
で特定の審判を持ってはいらっしゃらない方だったんですけれども彼女の宗教観とかし
せいかというようなものがドラマの話を通じて出てきているということがまあ
感じ取れたわけです
じゃあ専任のチャプレンの人はどうしてとに気がつかなかったんだろうなと思ったん
ですね
関税である彼女が答えをくれました
彼女曰くですね
彼はね話を聞きたいってきてるけど本当はそうじゃないのよ
お説教してきてるだけだよ
なあ私が言いたいことを聞いてくれないっていう風に言われました
もうひとつ非常に忘れられない患者さんとの話があります
彼女は年配のあの日系人の女性の方で私がお会いした時にはもう
バッキーの
がんのステージがで線曝気でいらっしゃってですねずっと1人で学校の先生として
素晴らしい人生を送って来られた方なんですけれどもそういう段階で最終的にご自身で
ホスピスに入られる決断をして
ようなそういう時期にお会いしました
で最初に今でも忘れないんですが彼女と話をしたのは
アメリカの
勝ち方行政についてなんですね彼女は日系人マイノリティーですから
あの非常に多様性を重視してそういう価値観を素晴らしいんだけれどもとはいえ本当の
ところは
例えばチェスト今日もそうです心境的な価値観が非常に強いと
そういうふうになると
いろんな募集矯正宗教観多様性死生観っていうのは認められている
見られるんだけれども本当のところどうなんだろうと
一番最後に亡くなったというんですね公的に認められて
a
その糖度場所っていうのは結局一つなんじゃないかっていう風に私の彼をじっと見て
彼女お話をしました
で話をしている中で私は特定の信仰を持ってない立場だったので
それからですいろいろ打ち明けてくださったんですね彼女自身毎晩
死の恐怖に
怯えているところがあるということとかそのときに実のところ本当の心のよりどころに
なっていうのは非常に素朴な信仰のあり方としての祈り
その時の子供の頃の家族との思い出そういったものが彼女自身の実は支えているんだと
いうことを話してくださったんですね
患者さんたちとの対話を通じてたくさんのことを学ばしてもらいました
対話というのは自由や民主主義のまあ実践と言いますか
a
そういったものとしてまー教育のあり方また岩というのは住んでその教育というものを
表している
体現してるものだと言う
ことができると思います
もともとですね言葉というのはまあ総合
作用与える変容する力があるものです
ですからまあ世界でそういった人々を仲介するつなぐような役割を持っている
そういうものでもあります
実際んですね
そういったその対話というのは
権威を持っている側の人たちから一方的に価値観の押し付けがもしなされるようであれ
ばそれは台湾にはならないわけです
本来そういったタイは相互の信頼関係を醸成して活
自律性
ですねそういったものを確保した上で行われるということが重要になってきます
8先ほどの2つの事例の中からも読み取れることなんですけれども
本当のところはですね
お互いの早慶というようなものが
見えない形で後ろに押しやられてですね
後ろその少数派の人たちマイノリティに当たるような人たちとってはですね一定の価値
観がもし見えない形で押し付けられた場合には二重三重のまあ
差別や排除というのを与えられる分
になりかねないということになりますそれは社会的スティグマというようなことですね
いわゆる個人的な屈辱とか
尊厳を奪われるような体験というものを本来ケアするためのものが場合によっては
さらなる違いを与えることにもなりかねないと
そういうことが実際ちゃんと検証されてるのかどうかということが非常に
実際のその対話を通じて私が学んだことです
そういった他者というと今日お話したような難民の方とかですねだけかと
皆さんもはれるかもしれませんけれどもちょっとあ
限らないわけでつまり皆さん自身の周りにも
例えば支援を必要としている方たち障害を持っている方たちとか社会で疎外され中の
方たちとか銀行に苦しんでいるような形ではたくさんいらっしゃいますあと私たちが気
がついてないだけで例えばお友達とか家族の中にも
そういう苦しみもしかしたら抱えている人たちもいるかもしれません
あのた岩手の自分自身も変えていくことなので
きれいごとじゃ済まないです制作大きいデビューになれば政治も経済も関わっています
一筋縄ではいかないです
ですけれども諦めず対話を続ける学び続ける
相手に手を差し伸べ続ける
それによって自分が王ローズ実は助けてもらうようなことにもあるかもしれません
そういったことがですね
実際にやり続ける中で本来あのあ
発見されるもそういったものが
本当のところを必要とされるスピリチュアルケアなんじゃないか
そういった形になった時に初めて世界とつながる世界をつなげるような多様な
本来的な支援活動の在り方としてスピリチュアルケアというのはあり得るんじゃないか
という風に考えています
ご静聴ありがとうございます